Prince William and Kate
Middleton arrived in Boston
for their first trip to the U.S.
in nearly ten years
And this is nice.
This is nice.
They met with Boston royalty
Matt Damon and Ben Affleck
while the prince
and princess of Wales
really are waking up in Boston
this morning.
The royal couple
sat courtside last night to watc
take on the Miami Heat.
William and Kate were spotted
clapping and cheering the player
on throughout the game.
It is their first trip abroad
since the death of Queen Elizabe
But tomorrow, William
and Kate will hand out awards
for their EARTHSHOT Prize.
While in the states,
the White House says
that they will also meet
with president biden
when he gets straight now.
Max Foster is live for us
in Boston on this side of the po
this morning.
Max, controversy
following the couple across the
Good morning to you.
Yeah, it's really
going to be one thing after anot
They had this racism scandal
back in the U.K.
just breaking as they landed.
Then they went to their first ce
and it was pouring with rain.
And the other special guests,
John Kerry and Caroline Kennedy,
couldn't make it to that.
Then they turn up to the game.
Last night
I was there, but just after the
that you heard there,
but there was booing
and there were chants of USA, US
But by the time I arrived
and was asking people about it,
I think it had more to do with,
you know, that Boston sense that
the cradle of the American Revol
the Boston Tea Party.
It was a really spirited event.
I'm not sure that was personal
But it does seem to be one thing
after another for this couple
during this tour.
But of course, everyone's
hearing about it.
Lots of publicity
around the event as well.
An honorary
member of the Buckingham
Palace, a Buckingham
Palace, has resigned and apologi
after questioning
whether a black British woman
was really British at a royal ch
event earlier this week.
Buckingham Palace did not name
the senior official
but released a statement
saying the individual
would like to apologize
and is stepping aside.
The British media has identified
the woman as Lady Susan Hussey.
She served as lady and waiting t
Queen Elizabeth
for more than 60 years
and is Prince William's godmothe
She's also the widow of a former
of the BBC's
Board of Governors
and was portrayed
in the latest season of Netflix
The Crown.
It's also been reported
that she was charged
with helping Meghan Markle
adjust to royal life.
How to be a royal, basically.
So this is just the latest incid
involving the royals and race.
During a trip to Jamaica,
this was back in March,
Prince William and Kate
were accused of reinforcing
colonial values.
Their decision to hold a parade
wrapped in royal linen
riding in this
in the same Land
Rover that the queen used
during a 1962
visit was viewed as Tone-Deaf.
The Guardian published
archive photos
archive papers
in June of 2021
which revealed that minority imm
and foreigners
were banned
from holding certain positions
at Buckingham Palace
until at least the late 1960s.
And Meghan and Harry cited racis
as one of the top reasons
why they decided to leave their
as royals.
Remember what they told Oprah
about
what an unnamed
member of the royal family
had to say about their first
child's skin tone? Watch
So we have in
tandem the
conversation of You
won't be given security.
So I'm going to be given a title
and also concerns
and conversations
about how dark
his skin might be when he's born
There is a conversation to hold
hold up there so
right now
there are several conversations,
a conversation with you, with Ha
about how dark your baby is goin
potentially, and what that would
or look like.
Well, joining me now is Trisha G
She's a CNN contributor
and host of The Week with Trisha
And Emily Nash,
a CNN royal commentator
and a royal editor at Hello maga
Hello to both of you.
She's covering
the royal visit, by the way.
Emily from Boston.
So I appreciate both of you join
So here we go again.
Yes. Talking about this.
I remember
we talked about it during the we
We talked
about during the queen's funeral
This is some deep stuff.
And so I'm wondering
what what does this mean?
Do you know the person who is in
in this, Anthony Joseph along?
She she's done some amazing work
And I think to me, this
this whole event was about women
and domestic violence.
So if somebody asks you
where you're from,
you tell them the organization
where you're from.
But this was sustained questioni
And a lot of us have been throug
You know,
people in the U.K., maybe 20,
30 years ago say, where you from
And I'd say, sorry.
No, where you really from?
I was born in Hackney.
Now, where are you really from?
And I thought, my God, hasn't
this conversation ever stopped?
So you weren't surprised at all?
No, no, I was shocked, but not s
And it goes,
this Lonnie is a credible figure
Yeah. Yeah. Gushing.
She's done
some amazing work for women
in domestic violence situations
in the African rugby in the area
I remember
this is what this function was a
Yeah.
Emily,
talk to me about Lady Hussey, pl
She is Prince William's grandmot
What's your take on this?
Is the word godmother.
Excuse me, godmother.
Are you surprised by this?
I am surprised.
And, you
know, it's really
shocking in terms of the high pr
nature of the event
for the queen consort.
This is
meant to be a huge moment for he
is completely overshadowed that.
And of course, it's
also really overshadowing
what's going on in Boston this w
So the timing of it is terrible,
but you know, moreover,
it's just inexcusable.
And I think
it's very interesting
that the palace
have been very quick
to act this time around.
It's possibly a changing of the
This might not have happened,
I think,
in the previous reign
as quickly as it has done.
Yeah,
because Charles
and the queen consort
has said that they want to moder
the royal family,
want wanted to be more diverse
and also limit
the roles and kind of roles
that Hussey had as a lady in wai
Absolutely.
And I think with Harry and Megha
in the family as well
and what they've done and also w
you know,
with with William and Catherine,
they are trying to move things f
I think they recognize that earl
at all was tone deaf.
They got very quick feedback.
So this quick out of the gate re
from Kensington Palace
is actually something very new.